foreign
[Music]
thank you
particular loved one but just focus on
that plane and you can say it out loud
yourself spit it if you are here today
please bend the flame to the left leg
just think about the loved one that you
would like to communicate with
imagine a picture of them in your mind
think of how you feel about them about
how they look any any strong memories if
you have you have both of them picture
their face how you feel when you're with
them
transfer with us
always
if you're there bend the flame to the
legs
hey
are you having trouble sleeping
Sawyer
there's something in my room
oh you were just having a right there
man
you're bleeding fell out of bed
say huh
[Music]
I found the culprit
might be time for that little guy to
come out
that's what Mom did whenever I had a
tooth that wouldn't come out on its own
she said that deep roots are on our
family
don't like letting go of things
so I'm gonna count to three
and slammed the door oh hurry hurry on a
hurry okay
one two all right we don't have to do it
[Music]
I'm so sorry you said on three I don't
know what happened
[Music]
um
hmm
[Music]
thank you
no time to cry
what do you think
happens to people after they die
what do you mean Sadie
do you mean do they go to heaven that's
not what I mean
are you one because maybe your mother is
still here
this may seem a little
out there but
when my father passed away
I felt like I could sense him
watching over me sometimes
if you pay close enough attention maybe
you'll start sensing your mom to
what about other things
what other things
I don't know it's hard to say it's like
a dark thing
I see well when did you start seeing
this dark thing
right after that man died
that makes perfect sense
okay
so what is it when there are scary
things we don't understand our minds try
to
fill in the blanks it's just like all
those spooky monsters you think are
hiding under your bed but we're going to
work on that together
okay
so it's not so scary
no we talked about this last time
when we have a phobia or fear something
Sometimes the best thing to do
is to face it and that's what we're
going to do today so this light is going
to be completely solid like it is right
now
and then gradually it's going to start
flashing slowly bringing the room down
until it's totally dark
so you can see that there's nothing to
be afraid of
okay
ready
okay good girl let's start
that's not so scary is it
see same old boring office as before
sister and me
you're doing okay no
hey
you're so close
no swear you got this
good job
[Music]